مطلب في كلمه التمديد
فذاكما سيجدد العمل باتفاقيه ينقضي اجلها
رسميا بعد ايام
امكن الصيف الماضي ابرام اتفاقيه في
اسطنبول بين روسيا واوكرانيا لتصدير
الحبوب في البحر الاسود برعايه تركيا
والامم المتحده
تضمنت الاتفاقيه تامين الصادرات الحبوب
العالقه في الموانئ الاوكرانيه الرئيسيه
الى العالم لمعالجه ازمه نقص الغذاء
اسهمت المباراه
التي تطاول ملايين البشر
لذلك تسمع من رئيس التركي قبل اسبوع من
انتهاء العمل بالاتفاقيه بان تمديدها
سيكون خطوه صعبا لكن لا ينبغي فيما يرى
الرجل وضع حد زمنيا للالتفاق
ويشير اردوغان ايضا الى امكانيه تاسيس ما
يسميه طريقه سلام من ممر الحبوب ورسم حدود
الله والعمل عليه بشكل جيد كما قال ماذا
الان عن موسكو التي لمحت مرارا الى
استعدادها للانسحاب من اتفاقيه اسطنبول ما
لم يتحقق تقدم في معالجه مخاوفها
بحثت الامم المتحده اخيرا مع الروس هواجس
وشكاوى على صله بالاتفاقيه التي علقوا
مشاركتهم فيها الشهر الماضي لبضعه ايام
يبدو ان تقدم قد حصل في جناب بما يسهل
تصدير المواد الغذائيه والاسمده من روسيا
بدون عوائق الى الاسواق العالميه لمكافحه
الازمه الغذائيه
ترى عواصم غربيه ان تمديد فتره اتفاقيه
شحن الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانيه هو ما
سيساهم حصرا في تحسين الوضع الغذائي على
مستوى العالم
لا تفتح اوكرانيا
او دولي
احسن نمبرز لقد دعوت جميع اعضاء الى
السيان الى اتخاذ كل الاجراءات الممكنه
لمنع روسيا من ممارسه الاعب الجوع مع
العالم يجب ابقاء ممر تصدير الحبوب من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه بعيدا عن ساحه المعركه
وروسيا ينبغي ان لا تستخدم هذا الممر
كورقه ابتزاز او نقطه استغلال في علاقاتها
الدوليه من يبت الزمن
على مساله التطبيق الكامل لمبادره الشحن
الامن للحبوب والمواد الغذائيه من موانئهم
ويثير الروس في المقابل مساله القيود
المفروضه على تصدير منتجاتهم الزراعيه
النجاح في مبادله هذه بتلك
الامال حتما في انفراج القريب لازمه
امداداته الرداء